what do you do when your parents don't
support your dream I'm gonna answer that
question in today's episode of lunch and
earn so Risa got a question for one of
my youtube viewers love you guys
awkwardly derpy who wrote in to say I
asked my parents for microphone for
YouTube and they said why are you
singing on YouTube that day I just gave
up so this is a really common issue
unfortunately and I really feel for you
it's really tough to continue on on your
dream when you have the people around
you who are the ones who are supposed to
believe in you not believe in your
dreams not encouraging you to be the
best you can be and the important thing
to remember is you have to figure out if
this is your life that you're going to
live or you're going to live somebody
else's version of your life and yes it's
your parents and that's tough and it's
harder to kind of leave them behind and
I don't necessarily think you have to
but you have to understand that you at
some point have to decide when you're
going to take charge of your own life
and live your dreams instead of letting
other people dictate what you can and
can't do so I have three pieces of
advice that I think Wow number one is
change the people that you hang out with
you're not going to change your parents
you're born with them when you're stuck
with them for the short term at least
and I'm sure they have a lot of love for
you and what they're saying is out of
love but what you should do now is
augment them with people who do support
your dreams I would start hanging out
with people who also want to be big on
YouTube and want to sing and love that
and I would join a band and be around
people who bring you up who make you
feel like you can do it who teach you
new things and believe in you and if
your friends don't then stop hanging out
with them as much and so now you need to
create a new social circle with people
who support and believe in your ideas
number two is study the success of great
singers whatever it is that you want to
do whatever big dream big goal you have
I would look at who has already
accomplished what they've done and how
can you model their success and so I
would look at singers that you look up
to and respect whoever it is it doesn't
matter look at the early stories look at
their early failures look at their early
troubles and people who didn't
even them and use their stories as one
motivation to think that they could get
through it so I can to and to get ideas
on what you can do right so you'll
notice that maybe this person entered
potala competition maybe this person
went on a radio show as a call-in maybe
this person went out and try to get an
agent whatever those strategies that
they use to become successful you can
leverage as well to apply it to your
craft to your story to your success to
help you reach that same path so studies
success of people that you look up to to
get those ideas as well as a motivation
to keep going number three is creative
routine that supports you if you really
want this badly and you have an
environment around you that sucks you
need to create a morning routine that
gets you started and set for the day so
whatever inspires you whatever motivates
you whatever pushes you to challenge
yourself and stretch your comfort zone
start that in the day so you're set up
for success right from when you wake up
so that's reading the story of a famous
musician or watching the video of the
early struggles and their success
whatever that is that gets you excited
and ready to go take action it was
listening to music that you love from
your favorite artists and feel like I
want to be like that guy or that girl
set up a morning routine that you follow
every single day so that you can get on
your horse charging the battle and
continue to believe in yourself so
change the people you hang out with
studies and success of famous people
who've already done what you want to do
and create a morning routine that helps
you believe in yourself thank you guys
so much for watching and thank you for
that great question my question for you
guys is I'd love to know if there's
somebody in your life who didn't believe
in you who put you down who is kind of a
little man in your life share that story
below because I think it could help
awkwardly Derby and other people just
like him or her to inspire to be
something better so leave your story in
the comments below thank you for
watching continue to believe and I'll
see
soon